Bernie wrote to me saying legality and
constitution aside do you wish you had
more privacy online sure I mean every
all else being equal I would love to
have the understanding that everything
that I'm doing online is completely
private I'm curious what your thought is
on this Jason but for years I've been
making it pretty clear that I assume
anything I'm doing on the internet is
being monitored so when I am sending
business-related e-mails back and forth
or whatever I am under the assumption
that there are authorities that could
figure out what it is I'm talking about
my email could be monitored whatever
when I am uh on facebook chat or
whatever I'm operating under the idea
that there's a very good chance that
this stuff is being monitored I don't
like it I would like more privacy online
I don't necessarily believe that the
laws that have been put in place that
allow for this type of surveillance our
number one completely uh moral which I
believe they are not but nor actually
productive we've heard that this type of
just bulk surveillance of people's
communications have not actually helped
to prevent terrorist attacks so yet in a
sort of vacuum why not I'd love to have
more privacy online but I'm at this
point operating under the impression
that everything I'm doing on my smart
phone and computer is probably logged
somewhere and could be looked at by
authorities other gonna see for me is
the vast amount of content and movies
that i watch I don't think there's
anything there's no value in seeing what
I'm doing I think you know via the
Patriot Act and NSA they know everything
about you big brother knows all but what
they really know i mean- watching some
movies we're gonna do about that but
would you like to have more privacy I
mean you are presumably using email to
communicate with people yeah but at the
same time I almost don't care because
what I'm saying to people you know let's
go let's go climbing this weekend or is
this the matters of national security do
I care they know where I am not really
so now the next question when somebody
says I don't care the NSA or whoever is
looking at what I'm doing is do you have
this sense of uh you only have to be
worried if you're doing something wrong
cuz I think that that's while that may
be absolutely true in many cases I think
that because of over criminalization you
might really not be worried because you
don't think you're doing anything wrong
but all of a sudden you're allowing for
basically what are fishing expeditions
to go on and number two those aren't
really the rules that our Constitution
and due process is based on the idea
that only criminals should be worried
because nobody who's not is ever going
to be incorrectly charged with the crime
or whatever I find it dangerous when
people say that I agree i think
everywhere could be communist China and
they could know everything you're doing
and actually prosecute you for it and I
don't agree I don't think the Patriot
Act should be there I don't think then
essay should be watching anyone it's a
huge waste of money yeah I'm manpower
but your problem sounds like it's more
from a practical standpoint yeah I don't
think it's gonna really do anything
that's gonna really affect me or anyone
I know because rent doing wrong but that
is excuse these people that are wasting
millions millions of tax dollars in time
invested in watching everybody I don't
think these fishing expeditions are
doing anything have we heard any stories
where they've actually caught anyone no
I mean the NSA we heard from James
clapper I believe it was that others a
whole bunch of plots that have been
foiled by the bulk surveillance and then
when asked to actually provide evidence
of that there was an admission that
actually we don't really have any
examples of it so yeah there's no doubt
about that uh but if you just say if I
could flip a switch and have more
privacy online sure I would absolutely
flip the switch